The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: [INAUDIBLE]
minus xi transpose t.
I just pick whatever notation
I want from a variable.
And let's say it's t.
So that's the least
squares estimator.
And it turns out that,
as I said last time,
it's going to be
convenient to think
of those things as matrices.
So here, I already have vectors.
I've already gone from one
dimension, just real valued
random variables through
random vectors when
I think of each xi, but if I
start stacking them together,
I'm going to have vectors
and matrices that show up.
So the first vector
I'm getting is
y, which is just a vector
where I have y1 to yn.
Then I have-- so that's
a boldface vector.
Then I have x, which is
a matrix where I have--
well, the first
coordinate is always 1.
So I have 1, and then x1 xp
minus 1, and that's-- sorry,
x1 xp minus 1, and
that's for observation 1.
And then I have the same
thing all the way down
for observation n.
OK, everybody
understands what this is?
So I'm just basically
stacking up all the xi's.
So this i-th row
is xi transpose.
I am just stacking them up.
And so if I want to write
all these things to be
true for each of
them, all I need to do
is to write a vector
epsilon, which
is epsilon 1 to epsilon n.
And what I'm going to have is
that y, the boldface vector,
now is equal to the
matrix x times the vector
beta plus the vector epsilon.
And it's really
just exactly saying
what's there, because for 2--
so this is a vector, right?
This is a vector.
And what is the
dimension of this vector?
n, so this is n observations.
And for all these-- for
two vectors to be equal,
I need to have all the
coordinates to be equal,
and that's exactly the same
thing as saying that this
holds for i equal 1 to n.
But now, when I have
this, I can actually
rewrite the sum for t equals--
sorry, for i equals 1 to
n of yi minus xi transpose
beta squared, this
turns out to be
equal to the Euclidean norm of
the vector y minus the matrix x
times beta squared.
And I'm going to
put a 2 here so we
know we're talking about
the Euclidean norm.
This just means this
is the Euclidean norm.
That's the one we've
seen before when
we talked about chi squared--
that's the square
norm is the sum
of the square of
the coefficients,
and then I take a
square root, but here I
have an extra square.
So it's really just the sum of
the square of the coefficients,
which is this.
And here are the coefficients.
So then, that I write this thing
like that, then minimizing--
so my goal here, now, is
going to solve minimum over t
in our p of y minus
x times t2 squared.
And just like we did
for one dimension,
we can actually write
optimality conditions for this.
I mean, this is a function.
So this is a function
from rp to r.
And if I want to minimize
it, all I have to do
is to take its gradient
and set it equal to 0.
So minimum, set gradient to 0.
So that's where it becomes
a little complicated.
Now I'm going to have to take
the gradient of this norm.
It might be a little
annoying to do.
But actually, what's
nice about those things--
I mean, I remember that it
was a bit annoying to learn.
I mean, it's just
basically rules of calculus
that you don't use that much.
But essentially, you can
actually expend this norm.
And you will see that
the rules are basically
the same as in one
dimension, you just
have to be careful about the
fact that matrices do not
commute.
So let's expand this thing.
y minus xt squared--
well, this is equal
to the norm of y
squared plus the norm
of x squared plus 2
times y transpose xt.
That's just expanding the
square in more dimensions.
And this, I'm actually going
to write as y squared plus--
so here, the norm
squared of this guy,
I always have that
the norm of x squared
is equal to x transpose x.
So I'm going to write
this as x transpose
x, so it's t transpose
x transpose xt
plus 2 times y transpose xt.
So now, if I'm going to take
the gradient with respect to t,
I have basically three
terms, and each of them
has some sort of a
different nature.
This term is linear
in t, and it's
going to differentiate
the same way
that I differentiate a times x.
I'm just going to keep the a.
This guy is quadratic.
t appears twice.
And this guy, I'm
going to pick up a 2,
and it's going to differentiate
just like when I differentiate
a times x squared.
It's 2 times ax.
And this guy is a constant
with respect to t,
so it's going to
differentiate to 0.
So when I compute the gradient--
now, of course, all of these
rules that I give you you
can check by looking at the
partial derivative with respect
to each coordinate.
But arguably, it's
much faster to know
the rules of differentiability.
It's like if I gave you
the function exponential x
and I said, what
is the derivative,
and you started
writing, well, I'm
going to write exponential x
plus h minus exponential ax
divided by h and let h go to 0.
That's a bit painful.
AUDIENCE: Why did
you transpose your--
why does x have
to be [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering why you times t
times the [INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
The transpose of 2ab
is b transpose a transpose.
If you're not sure
about this, just
make a and b have
different size,
and then you will see that
there's some incompatibility.
I mean, there's basically
only one way to not screw
that one up, so that's
easy to remember.
So if I take the gradient, then
it's going to be equal to what?
It's going to be 0
plus-- we said here,
this is going to
differentiate like-- so
think a times x squared.
So I'm going to have 2ax.
So here, basically, this guy is
going to go to x transpose xt.
Now, I could have
made this one go away,
but that's the same thing as
saying that my gradient is--
I can think of my
gradient as being
either a horizontal vector
or a vertical vector.
So if I remove this guy,
I'm thinking of my gradient
as being horizontal.
If I remove that guy, I'm
thinking of my gradient
as being vertical.
And that's what I want
to think of, typically--
vertical vectors,
column vectors.
And then this guy, well,
it's like these guys just
think a times x.
So the derivative is
just a, so I'm going
to keep only that part here.
Sorry, I forgot a minus
somewhere-- yeah, here.
Minus 2y transpose x.
And what I want is this
thing to be equal to 0.
So t, the optimal t, is called
beta hat and satisfies--
well, I can cancel the
2's and put the minus
on the other side,
and what I get
is that x transpose xt is
equal to y transpose x.
Yeah, that's not working for me.
Yeah, that's because when
I took the derivative,
I still need to make sure--
so it's the same question
of whether I want
things to be columns or rows.
So this is not a column.
If I remove that guy,
y transpose t is a row.
So I'm just going to take
the transpose of this guy
to make things work, and this is
just going to be x transpose y.
And this guy is x transpose
y so that I have columns.
So this is just the
linear equation in t.
And I have to solve it, so it's
of the form some matrix times
t is equal to another vector.
And so that's basically
in your system.
And the way to solve
it, at least formally,
is to just take the inverse
of the matrix on the left.
So if x transpose x is
invertible, then-- sorry,
that's beta hat is the t I want.
I get that beta hat is
equal to x transpose
x inverse x transpose y.
And that's the least
squares estimator.
So here, I use this condition.
I want it to be invertible so I
can actually write its inverse.
Here, I wrote, rank
of x is equal to p.
What is the difference?
Well, there's basically
no difference.
Basically, here,
I have to assume--
what is the size of the
matrix x transpose x?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
so what is the size?
AUDIENCE: p by p.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: p by p.
So this matrix is
invertible if it's a rank p,
if you know what rank means.
If you don't, that just rank
p means that it's invertible.
So it's full rank
and it's invertible.
And the rank of x
transpose x is actually
just the rank of x because this
is the same matrix that you
apply twice.
And that's all it's saying.
So if you're not comfortable
with the notion of rank
that you see here, just
think of this condition
just being the condition that
x transpose x is invertible.
And that's all it says.
What it means for it to be
invertible-- this was true.
We made no assumption
up to this point.
If x is not invertible,
it means that there
might be multiple
solutions to this equation.
In particular, for a matrix
to not be invertible,
it means that there's
some vector v.
So if x transpose x
is not invertible,
then this is equivalent
to there exists a vector
v, which is not 0, and such that
x transpose xv is equal to 0.
That's what it means
to not be invertible.
So in particular, if
beta hat is a solution--
so this equation is sometimes
called score equations,
because the gradient
is called the score,
and so you're just checking
if the gradient is equal to 0.
So if beta hat
satisfies star, then so
does beta hat plus lambda v for
all lambda in the real line.
And the reason is because,
well, if I start looking at--
what is x transpose x times
beta hat plus lambda v?
Well, by linearity, this
is just x transpose x
beta hat plus lambda
x transpose x times v.
But this guy is what?
It's 0, just because
that's what we assumed.
We assumed that x transpose
xv was equal to 0,
so we're left only with this
part, which, by star, is just
x transpose y.
So that means that x transpose
x beta hat plus lambda v
is actually equal to x transpose
y, which means that there's
another solution, which
is not just beta hat,
but any move of beta hat along
this direction v by any size.
So that's going to be
an issue, because you're
looking for one estimator.
And there's not just one,
in this case, there's many.
And so this is not
going to be well-defined
and you're going to
have some issues.
So if you want to talk about
the least squares estimator,
you have to make
this assumption.
What does it imply
in terms of, can I
think of p being too n,
for example, in this case?
What happens if
p is equal to 2n?
AUDIENCE: Well, then the rank
of your matrix is only p/2.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So the rank
of your matrix is only p/2,
so that means that this is
actually not going to happen.
I mean, it's not only
p/2, it's at most p/2.
It's at most the smallest of the
two dimensions of your matrix.
So if your matrix
is n times 2n, it's
at most n, which means that
it's not going to be full rank,
so it's not going
to be invertible.
So every time the dimension p
is larger than the sample size,
your matrix is not invertible,
and you cannot talk about
the least squares estimator.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
And it's actually a
very simple thing.
It's essentially saying,
well, if p is lower than n,
it means that you
have more parameters
to estimate than you have
equations to estimate it.
So you have this linear system.
There's one equation
per observation.
Each row, which was
each observation,
was giving me one equation.
But then the number of unknowns
in this linear system is p,
and so I cannot solve linear
systems that have more unknowns
than they have equations.
And so that's basically
what's happening.
Now, in practice, if
you think about what
data sets look like
these days, for example,
people are trying to
express some phenotype.
So phenotype is something you
can measure on people-- maybe
the color of your
eyes, or your height,
or whether you have diabetes
or not, things like this,
so things that are macroscopic.
And then they want to use
the genotype to do that.
They want to measure your-- they
want to sequence your genome
and try to use this to
predict whether you're going
to be responsive to a drug
or whether your r's are
going to be blue, or
something like this.
Now, the data sets
that you can have--
people, maybe, for a given study
about some sort of disease.
Maybe you will sequence the
genome of maybe 100 people.
n is equal to 100.
p is basically the number
of genes they're sequencing.
This is of the order of 100,000.
So you can imagine that this
is a case where n is much,
much smaller than p, and you
cannot talk about the least
squares estimator.
There's plenty of them.
There's not just
one line like that,
lambda times v that
you can move away.
There's basically an entire
space in which you can move,
and so it's not well-defined.
So at the end of this
class, I will give you
a short introduction
on how you do this.
This actually represents
more and more.
It becomes a more and more
preponderant part of the data
sets you have to deal
with, because people just
collect data.
When I do the
sequencing, the machine
allows me to sequence
100,000 genes.
I'm not going to stop at 100
because doctors are never
going to have cohorts of
more than 100 patients.
So you just collect
everything you can collect.
And this is true for everything.
Cars have sensors
all over the place,
much more than they
actually gather data.
There's data, there's--
we're creating,
we're recording
everything we can.
And so we need some new
techniques for that,
and that's what high-dimensional
statistics is trying to answer.
So this is way beyond
the scope of this class,
but towards the
end, I will give you
some hints about what can
be done in this framework
because, well, this is the new
reality we have to deal with.
So here, we're in a case
where p's less than n
and typically much
smaller than n.
So the kind of orders of
magnitude you want to have
is maybe p's of order 10 and
n's of order 100, something
like this.
So you can scale that,
but maybe 10 times larger.
So maybe you cannot solve this
guy b for b hat, but actually,
you can talk about
x times b hat,
even if p is larger than n.
And the reason is
that x times b hat
is actually something
that's very well-defined.
So what is x times b hat?
Remember, I started
with the model.
So if I look at this
definition, essentially, what I
had as the original
thing was that the vector
y was equal to x times beta
plus the vector epsilon.
That was my model.
So beta is actually
giving me something.
Beta is actually some
parameter, some coefficients
that are interesting.
But a good estimator
for-- so here, it
means that the
observations that I have
are of the form x times
beta plus some noise.
So if I want to adjust the
noise, remove the noise,
a good candidate to do
noise is x times beta hat.
x times beta hat is something
that should actually
be useful to me, which should
be close to x times beta.
So in the one-dimensional case,
what it means is that if I
have-- let's say this
is the true line,
and these are my
x's, so I have--
these are the true
points on the real line,
and then I have
my little epsilon
that just give me
my observations that
move around this line.
So this is one of
epsilons, say epsilon i.
Then I can actually
either talk--
to say that I
recovered the line,
I can actually talk about
recovering the right intercept
or recovering the right
slope for this line.
Those are the two parameters
that I need to recover.
But I can also say
that I've actually
found a set of
points that's closer
to being on the line that are
closer to this set of points
right here than the original
crosses that I observed.
So if we go back to
the picture here,
for example, what I could do
is say, well, for this point
here--
there was an x here--
rather than looking at this
dot, which was my observation,
I can say, well, now that
I've estimated the red line,
I can actually just
say, well, this point
should really be here.
And actually, I can
move all these dots
so that they're actually
on the red line.
And this should be a
better value, something
that has less noise than
the original y value
that I should see.
It should be close
to the true value
that I should be seeing
without the extra noise.
So that's definitely something
that could be of interest.
For example, in
imaging, you're not
trying to understand--
so when you do imaging,
y is basically an image.
So think of a pixel
image, and you just
stack it into one long vector.
And what you see
is something that
should look like some linear
combination of some feature
vectors, maybe.
So there's people created
a bunch of features.
They're called, for example,
Gabor frames or wavelet
transforms-- so just well-known
libraries of variables x such
that when you take linear
combinations of those guys,
this should looks like
a bunch of images.
And what you want
for your image--
you don't care what the
coefficients of the image
are in these bases
that you came up with.
What you care about is
the noise in the image.
And so you really
want to get x beta.
So if you want to
estimate x beta,
well, you can use x beta hat.
What is x beta hat?
Well, since beta hat is x
transpose x inverse x transpose
y, this is x transpose.
That's my estimator for x beta.
Now, this thing,
actually, I can define
even if I'm not low rank.
So why is this
thing interesting?
Well, there's a formula
for this estimator,
but actually, I can
visualize what this thing is.
So let's assume, for the
sake of illustration,
that n is equal to 3.
So that means that y lives
in a three-dimensional space.
And so let's say it's here.
And so I have my,
let's say, y's here.
And I also have a
plane that's given
by the vectors x1 transpose
x2 transpose, which
is, by the way, 1--
sorry, that's not
what I want to do.
I'm going to say that n is equal
to 3 and that p is equal to 2.
So I basically have two
vectors, 1, 1 and another one,
let's assume that
it's, for example, abc.
So those are my two vectors.
This is x1, and this is x2.
And those are my three
observations for this guy.
So what I want when
I minimize this,
I'm looking at the
point which can
be formed as the linear
combination of the columns
of x, and I'm trying to find
the guy that's the closest to y.
So what does it look like?
Well, the two points, 1, 1,
1 is going to be, say, here.
That's the point 1, 1, 1.
And let's say that
abc is this point.
So now I have a line that
goes through those two guys.
That's not really--
let's say it's
going through those two guys.
And this is the line which
can be formed by looking only
at linear combination.
So this is the line of
x times t for t in r2.
That's this entire
line that you can get.
Why is it-- yeah, sorry,
it's not just a line,
I also have to have
t, all the 0's thing.
So that actually
creates an entire plane,
which is going to be really
hard for me to represent.
I don't know.
I mean, maybe I shouldn't
do it in these dimensions.
So I'm going to do it like that.
So this plane here is the
set of xt for t and r2.
So that's a two-dimensional
plane, definitely goes to 0,
and those are all these things.
So think of a sheet of
paper in three dimensions.
Those are the things I can get.
So now, what I'm
going to have as y
is not necessarily
in this plane.
y is actually something
in this plane, x beta
plus some epsilon.
y is x beta plus epsilon.
So I start from
this plane, and then
I have this epsilon
that pushes me,
maybe, outside of this plane.
And what least squares
is doing is saying,
well, I know that epsilon
should be fairly small,
so the only thing I'm going to
be doing that actually makes
sense is to take y and
find the point that's
on this plane that's
the closest to it.
And that corresponds to doing
an orthogonal projection of y
onto this thing, and that's
actually exactly x beta hat.
So in one dimension, just
because this is actually
a little hard--
in one dimension, so
that's if p is equal to 1.
So let's say this is my point.
And then I have y, which
is in two dimensions,
so this is all on the plane.
What it does, this is my--
the point that's right here
is actually x beta hat.
That's how you find x beta hat.
You take your point
y and you project it
on the linear span
of the columns of x.
And that's x beta hat.
This does not tell you
exactly what beta should be.
And if you know a little
bit of linear algebra,
it's pretty clear, because
if you want to find beta hat,
that means that you
should be able to find
the coordinates of a point in
the system of columns of x.
And if those guys are
redundant, there's
not going to be unique
coordinates for these guys,
so that's why it's
actually not easy to find.
But x beta hat is
uniquely defined.
It's a projection.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And epsilon
is the distance
between the y and the--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: No, epsilon
is the vector that goes from--
so there's a true x beta.
That's the true one.
It's not clear.
I mean, x beta hat is unlikely
to be exactly equal to x beta.
And then the epsilon is the
one that starts from this line.
It's the vector that
pushes you away.
So really, this is this vector.
That's epsilon.
So it's not a length.
The lengths of epsilon
is the distance,
but epsilon is just the
actual vector that takes you
from one to the other.
So this is all in
two dimensions,
and it's probably much
clearer than what's here.
And so here, I claim
that this x beta hat--
so from this
picture, I implicitly
claim that forming this
operator that ticks y
and maps it into this vector
x times x transpose y, blah,
blah, blah, this should actually
be equal to the projection of y
onto the linear span
of the columns of x.
That's what I just drew for you.
And what it means
is that this matrix
must be the projection matrix.
So of course, anybody--
who knows linear algebra here?
OK, wow.
So what are the conditions
that a projection matrix
should be satisfying?
AUDIENCE: Squares
through itself.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Squares
through itself, right.
If I project twice,
I'm not moving.
If I keep on
iterating projection,
once I'm in the space
I'm projecting onto,
I'm not moving.
What else?
Do they have to be
symmetric, maybe?
AUDIENCE: If it's an
orthogonal projection.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, so this
is an orthogonal projection.
It has to be symmetric.
And that's pretty much it.
So from those things,
you can actually
get quite a bit of things.
But what's interesting
is that if you actually
look at the eigenvalues
of this matrix,
they should be either
0 or 1, essentially.
And they are 1 if the
eigenvector associated
is within this space,
and 0 otherwise.
And so that's basically
what you can check.
This is not an exercise
in linear algebra,
so I'm not going to go too
much into those details.
But this is essentially what
you want to keep in mind.
What's associated to
orthogonal projections
is Pythagoras theorem.
And that's something that's
going to be useful for us.
What it's essentially
telling is that if I
look at this norm squared, it's
equal to this norm squared--
sorry, this norm squared
plus this norm squared
is equal to this norm squared.
And that's something
the norm of y squared.
So Pythagoras tells me
that the norm of y squared
is equal to the norm of x beta
hat squared plus the norm of y
minus x beta hat squared.
Agreed?
It's just because I have
a straight angle here.
So that's this plus
this is equal to this.
So now, to define this,
I made no assumption.
Epsilon could be as wild.
I was just crossing my fingers
that epsilon was actually
small enough that
it would make sense
to project onto the linear
span, because I implicitly
assumed that epsilon did not
take me all the way there,
so that actually, it makes
sense to project back.
And so for that, I need to
somehow make assumptions
that epsilon is
well-behaved and that it's
completely wild, that
it's moving uniformly
in all directions of the space.
There's no privileged
direction where
it's always going,
otherwise, I'm
going to make a
systematic error.
And I need that those epsilons
are going to average somehow.
So here are the
assumptions we're
going to be making so
that we can actually
do some statistical inference.
The first one is that the
design matrix is deterministic.
So I started by saying the x--
I have xi, yi, and maybe
they're independent.
Here, they are, but the xi's, I
want to think as deterministic.
If they're not deterministic,
it can condition on them,
but otherwise,
it's very difficult
to think about this thing
if I think of those entries
as being random,
because then I have
the inverse of a random matrix,
and things become very, very
complicated.
So we're to think of those
guys as being deterministic.
We're going to think of the
model as being homoscedastic.
And actually, let me come
back to this in a second.
Homoscedastic-- well,
I mean, if you're
trying to find the
etymology of this word,
"homo" means the same,
"scedastic" means scaling.
So what I want to say
is that the epsilons
have the same scaling.
And since my third assumption is
that epsilon is Gaussian, then
essentially, what I'm going
to want is that they all share
the same sigma squared.
They're independent, so this
is definitely in the identity
covariance matrix.
And I want them to
be centered, as well.
That means that
there's no direction
that I'm always privileging when
I'm moving away from my plane
there.
So these are
important conditions.
It depends on how much
inference you want to do.
If you want to write t-tests,
you need all these assumptions.
But if you only want to
write, for example, the fact
that your least squares
estimator is consistent,
you really just need
the fact that epsilon
has variance sigma squared.
The fact that it's
Gaussian won't matter, just
like Gaussianity doesn't
matter for a large number.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the
first assumption
that x has to be
deterministic, but I just
made up this x1, x2--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
x is the matrix.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So most are random
variables, right?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: No,
that's the assumption.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I mean, once we collect the
data and put it in the matrix,
it becomes deterministic.
So maybe I'm missing something.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
So this is for the
purpose of the analysis.
I can actually assume that--
I look at my data,
and I think of this.
So what is the difference
between thinking
of data as deterministic or
thinking of it as random?
When I talked about random
data, the only assumptions
that I made were about
the distribution.
I said, well, if my x
is a random variable,
I want it to have this
variance and I want it to have,
maybe, this distribution,
things like this.
Here, I'm actually making
an assumption on the values
that I see.
I'm seeing that the value
that you give me is--
the matrix is
actually invertible.
x transpose x will
be invertible.
So I've never done
that before, assuming
that some random variable--
assuming that some Gaussian
random variable was positive,
for example.
We don't do that, because
there's always some probability
that things don't happen if
you make things at random.
And so here, I'm just going
to say, OK, forget about--
here, it's basically
a little stronger.
I start my assumption by saying,
the data that's given to me
will actually satisfy
those assumptions.
And that means that
I don't actually
need to make some modeling
assumption on this thing,
because I'm actually
putting directly
the assumption I want to see.
So here, either I
know sigma squared
or I don't know sigma squared.
So is that clear?
So essentially, I'm assuming
that I have this model, where
this guy, now, is
deterministic, and this
is some multivariate
Gaussian with mean 0
and covariance matrix
identity of rn.
That's the model I'm assuming.
And I'm observing this, and
I'm given this matrix x.
Where does this make sense?
You could say, well, if I think
of my rows as being people
and I'm collecting genes,
it's a little intense
to assume that I actually
know, ahead of time,
what I'm going to be seeing,
and that those things are
deterministic.
That's true, but it still
does not prevent the analysis
to go through, for one.
And second, a better example
might be this imaging example
that I described, where those
x's are actually libraries.
Those are libraries of
patterns that people
have created, maybe
from deep learning nets,
or something like this.
But they've created
patterns, and they
say that all images should
be representable as a linear
combination of those patterns.
And those patterns are
somewhere in books,
so they're certainly
deterministic.
Everything that's actually
written down in a book
is as deterministic as it gets.
Any questions about
those assumptions?
Those are the things we're
going to be working with.
There's only three of them.
One is about x.
Actually, there's
really two of them.
I mean, this guy
already appears here.
So there's two-- one on
the noise, one on the x's.
That's it.
Those things allow
us to do quite a bit.
They will allow us to--
well, that's
actually-- they allow
me to write the distribution
of beta hat, which is great,
because when I know the
distribution of my estimator,
I know it's fluctuations.
If it's centered around
the true parameter,
I know that it's going
to be fluctuating
around the true parameter.
And it should tell me
what kind of distribution
the fluctuations are.
I actually know how to
build confidence intervals.
I know how to build tests.
I know how to build everything.
It's just like when I told
you that asymptotically,
the empirical
variance was Gaussian
with mean theta and standard
deviation that depended on n,
et cetera, that's basically
the only thing I needed.
And this is what I'm
actually getting here.
So let me start
with this statement.
So remember, beta
hat satisfied this,
so I'm going to rewrite it here.
So beta hat was
equal to x transpose
x inverse x transpose y.
That was the definition
that we found.
And now, I also know that y was
equal to x beta plus epsilon.
So let me just replace y by
x beta plus epsilon here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it x transpose
x inverse x transpose y?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yes, x transpose.
Thank you.
So I'm going to replace
y by x beta plus epsilon.
So that's-- and here
comes the magic.
I have an inverse of
a matrix, and then
I have the true matrix, I
have the original matrix.
So this is actually the
identity times beta.
And now this guy, well,
this is a Gaussian,
because this is a
Gaussian random vector,
and I just multiply it by
a deterministic matrix.
So we're going to use the rule
that if I have, say, epsilon,
which is n0 sigma, then
b times epsilon is n0--
can somebody tell me what the
covariance matrix of b epsilon
is?
AUDIENCE: What is
capital B in this case?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
It's just a matrix.
And for any matrix, I mean any
matrix that I can premultiply--
that I can postmultiply
with epsilon.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: b transpose b.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: b transpose?
AUDIENCE: Times b.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
And sigma is gone.
AUDIENCE: Oh,
times sigma, sorry.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That's the matrix, right?
AUDIENCE: b transpose sigma b.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Almost.
Anybody wants to take a
guess at the last one?
I think we've removed
all other possibilities.
It's b sigma b transpose.
So if you ever answered
to the question,
do you know Gaussian
random vectors,
but you did not know that,
there's a gap in your knowledge
that you need to fill,
because that's probably
the most important property
of Gaussian vectors.
When you multiply
them by matrices,
you have a simple rule on how
to update the covariance matrix.
So here, sigma is the identity.
And here, this is the
matrix b that I had here.
So what this is is, basically,
n, some multivariate n,
of course.
Then I'm going to have 0.
And so what I need to do is
b times the identity times b
transpose, which is
just b b transpose.
And what is it going to tell me?
It's x transpose x--
sorry, that's inverse--
inverse x transpose, and then
the transpose of this
guy, which is x x
transpose x inverse transpose.
But this matrix is
symmetric, so I'm actually
not going to make the
transpose of this guy.
And again, magic shows up.
Inverse times the
matrix of those two guys
cancel, and so this is
actually equal to beta
plus some n0 x
transpose x inverse.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm a little
lost on the [INAUDIBLE]..
So you define that as the
b matrix, and what happens?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So I
just apply this rule, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
if I multiply a matrix
by a Gaussian, then let's
say this Gaussian had
mean 0, which is the
case of epsilon here,
then the covariance
matrix that I get
is b times the original
covariance matrix times b
transpose.
So all I did is write this
matrix times the identity
times this matrix transpose.
And the identity, of course,
doesn't play any role,
so I can remove it.
It's just this matrix,
then the matrix transpose.
And what happened?
So what is the transpose
of this matrix?
So I used the fact that if I
look at x transpose x inverse x
transpose, and now I look at the
whole transpose of this thing,
that's actually equal 2.
And I use the rule that ab
transpose is b transpose
a transpose-- let me finish--
and it's x x
transpose x inverse.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I thought the--
for epsilon, it
was sigma squared.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Oh, thank you.
There's a sigma
squared somewhere.
So this was sigma squared times
the identity, so I can just
pick up a sigma
squared anywhere.
So here, in our case, so
for epsilon, this is sigma.
Sigma squared
times the identity,
that's my covariance matrix.
You seem perplexed.
AUDIENCE: It's just
a new idea for me
to think of a maximum likelihood
estimator as a random variable.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Oh, it should not be.
Any estimator is
a random variable.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah,
that's a good point.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
[LAUGHS] And I have not
told you that this was
the maximum likelihood
estimator just yet.
The estimator is
a random variable.
There's a word-- some
people use estimate just
to differentiate the
estimator while you're
doing the analysis with random
variables and the values
when you plug in the
numbers in there.
But then, of course, people use
estimate because it's shorter,
so then it's confusing.
So any questions about
this computation?
Did I forget any other
Greek letter along the way?
All right, I think we're good.
So one thing that it
says-- and actually,
thank you for
pointing this out--
I said there's actually a
little hidden statement there.
By the way, this
answers this question.
Beta hat is of the form beta
plus something that's centered,
so it's indeed of the form
Gaussian with mean beta
and covariance matrix sigma
squared x transpose x inverse.
So that's very nice.
As long as x transpose
x is not huge,
I'm going to have something
that is close to what I want.
Oh, sorry, x transpose
x inverse is not huge.
So there's a hidden
claim in there,
which is that least
squares estimator
is equal to the maximum
likelihood estimator.
Why does the maximum
likelihood estimator just
enter the picture now?
We've been talking about
regression for the past 18
slides.
And we've been talking
about estimators.
And I just dumped on you
the least squares estimator,
but I never really came back
to this thing that we know--
maybe the method of moments,
or maybe the maximum likelihood
estimator.
It turns out that those
two things are the same.
But if I want to talk about a
maximum likelihood estimator,
I need to have a likelihood.
In particular, I need
to have a density.
And so if I want
a density, I have
to make those assumptions,
such as the epsilons have
this Gaussian distribution.
So why is this the maximum
likelihood estimator?
Well, remember, y is x
transpose beta plus epsilon.
So I actually have
a bunch of data.
So what is my model here?
Well, its the
family of Gaussians
on n observations with
mean x beta, variance sigma
squared identity,
and beta lives in rp.
Here's my family
of distributions.
That's the possible
distributions for y.
And so in particular, I
can write the density of y.
Well, what is it?
It's something that
looks like p of x--
well, p of y, let's say,
is equal to 1 over--
so now its going to be a
little more complicated,
but its sigma squared times 2
pi to the p/2 exponential minus
norm of y minus x beta squared
divided by 2 sigma squared.
So that's just the
multivariate Gaussian density.
I just wrote it.
That's the density of
a multivariate Gaussian
with mean x beta and
covariance matrix sigma squared
times the identity.
That's what it is.
So you don't have to
learn this by heart,
but if you are familiar with
the case where p is equal to 1,
you can check that you recover
what you're familiar with,
and this makes sense
as an extension.
So now, I can actually
write my log likelihood.
How many observations do
I have of this vector y?
Do I have n observations of y?
I have just one, right?
Oh, sorry, I shouldn't
have said p, this is n.
Everything is in dimension n.
So I can think of either having
n independent observations
of each coordinate,
or I can think
of having just one
observation of the vector y.
So when I write
my log likelihood,
it's just the log
of the density at y.
And that's the
vector y, which I can
write as minus n/2
log sigma squared
2 pi minus 1 over 2 sigma
squared norm of y minus x beta.
And that's, again,
my boldface y.
And what is my maximum
likelihood estimator?
Well, this guy does
not depend on beta.
And this is just a constant
factor in front of this guy.
So it's the same thing
as just minimizing,
because I have a minus
sign, over all beta and rp.
y minus x beta squared,
and that's my least squares
estimator.
Is there anything that's
unclear on this board?
Any question?
So all I used was-- so I
wrote my log likelihood, which
is just the log
of this expression
where y is my observation.
And that's indeed the
observation that I have here.
And that was just some constant
minus some constant times
this quantity that
depends on beta.
So maximizing this whole
thing is the same thing
as minimizing only this thing.
The minimizers are the same.
And so that tells me
that I actually just
have to minimize
the squared norm
to get my maximum
likelihood estimator.
But this used, heavily, the
fact that I could actually
write exactly what
my density was,
and that when I took
the log of this thing,
I had exactly the square
norm that showed up.
If I had a different
density, if, for example,
I assumed that my coordinates
of epsilons were, say, iid
double exponential
random variables.
So it's just half
of an exponential.
And the plus is half of an
exponential on the negatives.
So if I said that,
then this would not
have the square
norm that shows up.
This is really
idiosyncratic to Gaussians.
If I had something
else, I would have,
maybe, a different norm
here, or something different
measures the difference
between y and x beta.
And that's how you come up
with other maximum likelihood
estimators that leads
to other estimators that
are not the least squares--
maybe the least
absolute deviation,
for example, or this
fourth movement,
for example, that you
suggested last time.
So I can come up with a
bunch of different things,
and they might be tied--
maybe I can come up from them
from the same perspective
that I came from the
least squares estimator.
I said, let's just
do something smart
and check, then, that it's
indeed the maximum likelihood
estimator.
Or I could just start
with the modeling on--
and check, then, what happens--
what was the implicit assumption
that I put on my noise.
Or I could start with the
assumption of the noise,
compute the maximum
likelihood estimator
and see what it turns into.
So that was the first thing.
I've just proved to
you the first line.
And from there, you
can get what you want.
So all the other lines
are going to follow.
So what is beta hat-- so
for example, let's look
at the second line,
the quadratic risk.
Beta hat minus beta,
from this formula,
has a distribution,
which is n n0,
and then I have x
transpose x inverse.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the
dimension be p on the board?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Sorry,
the dimension of what?
AUDIENCE: Oh beta
hat minus beta.
Isn't beta only a p dimensional?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh, yeah,
you're right, you're right.
That was all p
dimensional there.
Yeah.
So if b here, the matrix
that I'm actually applying,
has dimension p times n--
so even if epsilon was an n
dimensional Gaussian vector,
then b times epsilon is a p
dimensional Gaussian vector
now.
So that's how I
switch from p to n--
from n to p.
Thank you.
So you're right, this is beta
hat minus beta is this guy.
And so in particular, if
I look at the expectation
of the norm of beta hat minus
beta squared, what is it?
It's the expectation of the
norm of some Gaussian vector.
And so it turns out--
so maybe we don't have--
well, that's just also a
property of a Gaussian vector.
So if epsilon is n0 sigma,
then the expectation
of the norm of epsilon squared
is just the trace of sigma.
Actually, we can
probably check this
by saying that this is
the sum from j equal 1
to p of the expectation of beta
hat j minus beta j squared.
Since beta j squared is
the expectation-- beta j
is the expectation of beta hat.
This is actually equal
to the sum from j equal 1
to p of the variance
of beta hat j,
just because this is the
expectation of beta hat.
And how do I read the variances
in a covariance matrix?
There are just the
diagonal elements.
So that's really just sigma jj.
And so that's really equal to--
so that's the sum of
the diagonal elements
of this matrix.
Let's call it sigma.
So that's equal to the trace
of x transpose x inverse.
The trace is the sum of the
diagonal elements of a matrix.
And I still had something else.
I'm sorry, this
was sigma squared.
I forget it all the time.
So the sigma squared comes out.
It's there.
And so the sigma
squared comes out
because the trace is
a linear operator.
If I multiply all the entries
of my matrix by the same number,
then all the diagonal
elements are multiplied
by the same number,
so when I sum them,
the sum is multiplied
by the same number.
So that's for the
quadratic risk of beta hat.
And now I need to tell
you about x beta hat.
x beta hat was something
that was actually telling me
that that was the point that
I reported on the red line
that I estimated.
That was my x beta hat.
That was my y minus the noise.
Now, this thing here--
so remember, we had this line,
and I had my observation.
And here, I'm really trying to
measure this distance squared.
This distance is actually
quite important for me
because it actually shows up
in the Pythagoras theorem.
And so you could actually
try to estimate this thing.
So what is the prediction error?
So we said we have y minus
x beta hat, so that's
the norm of this thing
we're trying to compute.
But let's write this for
what it is for one second.
So we said that beta
hat was x transpose
x inverse extra transpose
y, and we know that y is
x transpose beta plus epsilon.
So let's write this--
x beta plus epsilon plus x.
And actually, maybe I
should not write it.
Let me keep the y
for what it is now.
So that means that
I have, essentially,
the identity of rn times y
minus this matrix times y.
So I can factor
y out, and that's
the identity of rn
minus x x transpose
x inverse x transpose,
the whole thing times y.
We call this matrix p because
this was the projection matrix
onto the linear span of the x's.
So that means that if I take a
point x and I apply p times x,
I'm projecting onto the linear
span of the columns of x.
What happens if I do
i minus p times x?
It's x minus px.
So if I look at the
point on which--
so this is the point
on which I project.
This is x.
I project orthogonally
to get p times x.
And so what it means
is that this operator i
minus px is actually giving me
this guy, this vector here--
x minus p times x.
Let's say this is 0.
This means that this
vector, I can put it here.
It's this vector here.
And that's actually the
orthogonal projection
of x onto the orthogonal
complement of the span
of the columns of x.
So if I project x, or if I
look of x minus its projection,
I'm basically projecting
onto two orthogonal spaces.
What I'm trying to say
here is that this here
is another projection
matrix p prime.
That is just the projection
matrix onto the orthogonal--
projection onto orthogonal
of column span of x.
Orthogonal means
the set of vectors
that's orthogonal to everyone
in this linear space.
So now, when I'm doing
this, this is exactly what--
I mean, in a way, this is
illustrating this Pythagoras
theorem.
And so when I want to compute
the norm of this guy, the norm
squared of this guy,
I'm really computing--
if this is my y now,
this is px of y,
I'm really controlling the
norm squared of this thing.
So if I want to compute
the norm squared--
so I'm almost there.
So what am I projecting here
onto the orthogonal projector?
So here, y, now,
I know that y is
equal to x beta plus epsilon.
So when I look at this
matrix p prime times y,
It's actually p prime times
x beta plus p prime times
epsilon.
What's happening to
p prime times x beta?
Let's look at this picture.
So we know that p prime takes
any point here and projects it
orthogonally on this guy.
But x beta is actually
a point that lives here.
It's something that's
on the linear span.
So where do all the points
that are on this line
get projected to?
AUDIENCE: The origin.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
The origin, to 0.
They all get projected to 0.
And that's because I'm
basically projecting
something that's on the column
span of x onto its orthogonal.
So that's always 0
that I'm getting here.
So when I apply
p prime to y, I'm
really just applying
p prime to epsilon.
So I know that now,
this, actually,
is equal to the norm of
some multivariate Gaussian.
What is the size
of this Gaussian?
What is the size of this matrix?
Well, I actually had it there.
It's i n, so it's n dimensional.
So it's some n
dimensional with mean 0.
And what is the
covariance matrix
of p prime times epsilon?
AUDIENCE: p p transpose.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
p prime p prime transpose,
which we just said p
prime transpose is p,
so that's p squared.
And we see that when
we project twice,
it's as if we
projected only once.
So here, this is n0 p
prime p prime transpose.
That's the formula for
the covariance matrix.
But this guy is actually equal
to p prime times p prime,
which is equal to p prime.
So now, what I'm looking for is
the norm squared of the trace.
So that means that
this whole thing here
is actually equal to the trace.
Oh, did I forget
again a sigma squared?
Yeah, I forgot it only
here, which is good news.
So I should assume that
sigma squared is equal to 1.
So sigma squared's here.
And then what I'm left
with is sigma squared
times the trace of p prime.
At some point, I mentioned that
the eigenvalues of a projection
matrix were actually 0 or 1.
The trace is the sum
of the eigenvalues.
So that means that
the trace is going
to be an integer number as the
number of non-0 eigenvalues.
And the non-0
eigenvalues are just
the dimension of the space
onto which I'm projecting.
Now, I'm projecting from
something of dimension n
onto the orthogonal of
a space of dimension p.
What is the dimension
of the orthogonal
of a space of dimension
p when thought
of space in dimension n?
AUDIENCE: [? 1. ?]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: N minus p--
that's the so-called rank
theorem, I guess, as a name.
And so that's how I get
this n minus p here.
This is really just
equal to n minus p.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Here, we're taking the
expectation of the whole thing.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yes, you're right.
So that's actually
the expectation
of this thing that's
equal to that.
Absolutely.
But I actually have much better.
I know, even, that the
norm that I'm looking at,
I know it's going
to be this thing.
What is going to be the
distribution of this guy?
Norm squared of a
Gaussian, chi squared.
So there's going to be some
chi squared that shows up.
And the number of
degrees of freedom
is actually going to
be also n minus p.
And maybe it's
actually somewhere--
yeah, right here-- n
minus p times sigma hat
squared over sigma squared.
This is my sigma hat squared.
If I multiply n minus p, I'm
left only with this thing,
and so that means that I
get sigma squared times--
because they always
forget my sigma squared--
I get sigma squared
times this thing.
And it turns out that the
square norm of this guy
is actually exactly chi
squared with n minus b
degrees of freedom.
So in particular, so we
know that the expectation
of this thing is equal to
sigma squared times n minus p.
So if I divide both
sides by n minus p,
I'm going to have that
something whose expectation is
sigma squared.
And this something, I
can actually compute.
It depends on y,
and x that I know,
and beta hat that
I've just estimated.
I know what n is.
And pr's are the
dimensions of my matrix x.
So I'm actually given an
estimator whose expectation
is sigma squared.
And so now, I actually
have an unbiased estimator
of sigma squared.
That's this guy right here.
And it's actually super useful.
So those are called the--
this is the normalized
sum of square residuals.
These are called the residuals.
Those are whatever
is residual when
I project my points onto the
line that I've estimated.
And so in a way, those guys--
if you go back to this picture,
this was yi and this was
xi transpose beta hat.
So if beta hat is close
to beta, the difference
between yi and xi
transpose beta should
be close to my epsilon i.
It's some sort of epsilon i hat.
Agreed?
And so that means
that if I think
of those as being
epsilon i hat, they
should be close to epsilon
i, and so their norm
should be giving me something
that looks like sigma squared.
And so that's why it
actually makes sense.
It's just magical that
everything works out together,
because I'm not projecting
on the right line,
I'm actually projecting
on the wrong line.
But in the end, things
actually work out pretty well.
There's one thing--
so here, the theorem
is that this thing not only
has the right expectation,
but also has a chi
squared distribution.
That's what we just discussed.
So here, I'm just
telling you this.
But it's not too
hard to believe,
because it's actually
the norm of some vector.
You could make this
obvious, but again, I
didn't want to bring in
too much linear algebra.
So to prove this,
you actually have
to diagonalize the matrix p.
So you have to invoke the
eigenvalue decomposition
and the fact that the norm
is invariant by rotation.
So for those who are
familiar with, what I can do
is just look at the
decomposition of p
prime into ud u transpose where
this is an orthogonal matrix,
and this is a diagonal
matrix of eigenvalues.
And when I look at the
norm squared of this thing,
I mean, I have,
basically, the norm
squared of p prime
times some epsilon.
It's the norm of ud u
transpose epsilon squared.
The norm of a
rotation of a vector
is the same as the norm of the
vector, so this guy goes away.
This is not actually--
I mean, you don't have
to care about this if you
don't understand what I'm
saying, so don't freak out.
This is really for
those who follow.
What is the distribution
of u transpose epsilon?
I take a Gaussian vector that
has covariance matrix sigma
squared times the
[? identity, ?] and I basically
rotate it.
What is its distribution?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The same.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
It's the same.
It's completely invariant,
because the Gaussian
think of all directions
as being the same.
So it doesn't really matter if
I take a Gaussian or a rotated
Gaussian.
So this is also a
Gaussian, so I'm
going to call it epsilon prime.
And I am left with just
the norm of epsilon primes.
So this is the sum of the
dj's squared times epsilon
j squared.
And we just said that
the eigenvalues of p
are either 0 or 1,
because it's a projector.
And so here, I'm going
to get only 0's and 1's.
So I'm really just
summing a certain number
of epsilon i squared.
So square root of
standard Gaussians--
sorry, with a sigma
squared somewhere.
And basically, how
many am I summing?
Well, the n minus p, the
number of non-0 eigenvalues
of p prime.
So that's how it shows up.
When you see this, what
theorem am I using here?
Cochran's theorem.
This is this magic book.
I'm actually going to dump
everything that I'm not going
to prove to you and say, oh,
this is actually Cochran's.
No, Cochran's theorem
is really just
telling me something about
orthogonality of things,
and therefore,
independence of things.
And Cochran's
theorem was something
that I used when I
wanted to use what?
That's something I used
just one slide before.
Student t-test, right?
I used Cochran's theorem
to see that the numerator
and the denominator of
the student statistic
were independent of each other.
And this is exactly what
I'm going to do here.
I'm going to actually write
a test to test, maybe,
if the beta j's are equal to 0.
I'm going to form a numerator,
which is beta hat minus beta.
This is normal.
And we know that beta hat
has a Gaussian distribution.
I'm going to
standardized by something
that makes sense to me.
And I'm not going
to go into details,
because we're out of time.
But there's the sigma
hat that shows up.
And then there's a gamma
j, which takes into account
the fact that my x's--
if I look at the distribution of
beta, which is gone, I think--
yeah, beta is gone.
Oh, yeah, that's where it is.
The covariance matrix depends
on this matrix x transpose x.
So this will show
up in the variance.
In particular, diagonal elements
are going to play a role here.
And so that's what
my gammas are.
The gammas is the j's diagonal
element of this matrix.
So we'll resume
that on Tuesday, so
don't worry too much if
this is going too fast.
I'm not supposed to
cover it, but just so you
get a hint of why Cochran's
theorem actually was useful.
So I don't know if we
actually ended up recording.
I have your homework.
And as usual, I will
give it to you outside.